we're going to play a little game with
let's do it speedway let's do some
oscars
okay you know ross and i thrive on this
kevin because we like to
get every answer right and i i i'm so
excited you ready rob oh yeah teammates
let's go kev hit it all right we're
going to play a
a little game of who won it uh you know
the drill i'll ask you a trivia question
you two confer and tell me who won it
okay all right here we go
all right we all know that meryl streep
got the most nominations ever
at 21 but who has won the most best
actress awards ever
was it catherine hepburn betty davis or
elizabeth
taylor i know this hands down do you
know really
elizabeth taylor it is a katherine
hepburn hey katherine hepburn okay i'm
going with rossi because when i deviate
i lose are you
are you sure okay 100 katherine hepburn
it is she has won four best actress
oscars spanning nearly 50 years meryl
has three betty davis and liz taylor are
no slashers because they have two
ross kudos to you let's keep it going i
don't know a lot but i know a lot about
this
okay okay who gave the shortest
acceptance speech of the last 25 years
saying just six words
when he won best supporting actor was it
denzel washington
jack nicholson or joe pesci i know
is it nicholson it is joe pesci for good
fellows
oh really it is joe pesci for good
fellows
what did he say whatever the sixth one
just said like thank you for this or
something what do you say
it was my privilege thank you yeah now
matthew mcconaughey ranks with the most
words at 549
for his win for dallas buyers 2014.
right and we're still listening
all right only one brother and sister do
have
duo have won both an oscar for acting
was it maggie and jake gyllenhaal ethel
and lionel
barrymore shirley mclean and warren
beatty
okay first of all i always forget that
shirley maclaine and warren beatty
were brother and sister yeah and they
both have oscars but
he won for directing so and this is
oscars for acting so is it
is it b true i mean i know lionel won
an academy award but i didn't believe
what about ethel
i thought he was the only barrymore that
ever won and i know my grandfather
never won i've never even been nominated
not yet
there you go not yet i'm like believe it
or not dude neither have i
um that's shocking and bs
i have to say i would say b ah okay you
would go
raw she would go with the barrymores i
would because i know a neither one of
them
and not that it's not the gyllenhaals
i'm gonna go with shirley maclaine and
warren beatty on this one
you know what stick with ross because he
knows what he's talking about it's your
people's
the barrett morris lionel won in 1931
for a free soul than ethel in 1944
none but the lonely heart maggie and
jake both got nominations shirley went
for terms of endearment
warren nominated for reds but never won
believe it or not
hmm well okay drew that's your family
um you know what's so funny i never knew
that athel won
i knew that lionel won and i i know that
john
i i don't even know if he was nominated
ever
or or one um
somebody in your family's gonna call you
today um what oscar
host wins the title for longest running
oscars ever at four hours in 23 minutes
was it
johnny carson billy crystal or whoopi
goldberg
okay this one i don't know drew no i'm
gonna
guess whoopi okay i love whoopi lockus
i'm totally guessing here
ross you haven't missed one yet we'll be
in 2002 her fourth time hosting she's
the woman who has hosted the oscars most
in history also so i'm glad to know that
we'll be a groundbreaker well done kevin